hi everyone it's joanna here i'm super
excited because i've put together
a 30 day workout plan to get you fitter
and stronger from home this program has
a combination of heat workouts and
strength training
to boost your metabolism burn calories
lose weight and scalp lean muscle mass
effectively
all you need is only 30 minutes a day to
get the workouts done
and the best part is you can do it at
home in a small space
with minimal equipment all my workouts
are done in real time
and i will be guiding you through the
entire class making sure that you're
doing the exercises correctly
and to keep you motivated plus we'll be
having
lots of fun if at all you feel that the
exercises are too tough
then feel free to choose the easier
version and slowly progress
through the weeks i've created a
playlist on my youtube channel with
all the workouts as well as a workout
calendar available on my website
which you can download and print it out
all the links are in my description box
below
so let's get active and get moving from
the comfort of your own home
do remember to take pictures or videos
share it on your
ig and facebook and tag me at joanna's
official
hashtag jso 30 day fit challenge
share this workout plan with your
friends and get them to join you
be ready for the after burn and amazing
results
all the best